contrary to popular belief the numbers
which were on the board are not the main
thing that I'm looking for I'm looking
for the process okay so for that reason
I want to remind you and I want to see
if you're on the same page with me
you've got six things that'll be the
last of you here and there are six
different ways to find each so let's
begin at the left hand side first
recently we looked at spheres the
surface area of a sphere what is this
how do you read that for pi what's that
that's this and of course you had to
notice we provide a diameter so your
hands are harder to get the radius so
big tick great okay now this monstrous
thing on my butt again I'll come to
whether it's correct or not but where
does it come from what is the formula
for you very good
4/3 PI R cubed just check out do you get
that yeah just a quick note the radius
we've already button is 150 when you
cube that number you get a number with
actually lots of zeros on you get a very
round figure
however this answer is not round does
anyone know why it's not a round number
like a nice sort of easy with lots of
zeros like 22 million or something like
that
yeah very good this guy isn't it pi is a
weird number it's decimal points they go
on forever and they never ever ever
repeat which is crazy when you think
about which is why you can do cool
things like find your birthday or your
phone number in PI it's in there
somewhere there are websites so can I go
show here to a grease who raised one
four one three seven yeah got a few yep
excellent many of them okay let's have a
look at this this coating here so this
one was also a tricky ones let me remind
you the surface area of a cone cone has
the two parts it's got the bit of a
bottom which is uh
so so therefore now square but then
you've got this real part that we
constructed the what would you call that
again yeah it becomes a sector
I suppose the name it is it's the curved
surface area as opposed to the flat part
do you agree with that do you remember
what was that component when I r L which
is why that's a sneaky one right that's
the slide touch right so that's the
tenth yeah
so that moment did anyone get a
different number for this so mark what
you get okay now can I just uh could you
put your pens down because this is no
really I'm so glad that this answer is
here okay put your pens down I want you
to make him go to this when other she
come to the board I said hey don't worry
wait a bit of a hurry not much space
don't include you working it's fine well
if you do no big deal but if you were
doing this in your book I expect every
single one of you should have this line
or at least this line with numbers in it
before you get to the punchline here's
why something has gone wrong here that's
fine things happen all the time there's
lots of things to substitute is
multiplied so this could have gone wrong
when I calculate off whatever if the
only difference was a single number that
was input incorrectly but everything
else is fine chances are this would be a
tumor question I was putting this in at
year 10 5.3 exam I put two marks on it
and someone who has this is the answer
but it certainly they're working it
shows me they get it they've just made a
minor error is going to get amok however
if all you've got is an answer I've can
only see that it's wrong and there's no
other evidence as to like where'd you
get this wrong did you guess it just
passed random numbers in your calculator
I is the market can tell so that's why
this line is really important this line
you can still get your luck if I can see
where it came from
does that make sense yeah working really
important volume I check that one out
myself I was just punching you around a
minute what is the volume of a code
again what do we
I squared H and hopefully you recognize
that part there as just a cylinder and
this is just a third of that to create
the pyramid tension okay the last one
was the easiest surface area what's
going on here I love what the working is
here and I love that there are these
brackets here which aren't necessary but
they mean for what does it mean yes
perfect
absolutely so every face here is the
same because it's a cube so even though
adding this brackets doesn't change the
number bottom it helps us see oh that's
one thing and these x 6y six faces
perfect so the tick volume is pretty
straightforward main vein Fang is a
rectangular prism in fact it's just they
all have